rings you know they made another one I'd
do it again
Samaras coming she's going to get
everybody is it going to be puddles of
water and TVs and static and so some
people stumble across an old VHS tape
that's creepy and if you watch it you
die in seven days you all probably know
that what you don't know is at this time
this one has QuickTime files so we're
getting into uncharted territory here
guys truthfully I thought this movie was
going to be complete shit I mean it has
one of the worst horror trailers I've
seen in a long time and it's been pushed
back multiple times it was originally
last going to be coming out around
Halloween I was even doing a ring series
I reviewed the original Japanese film
and the American remake and I was just
about to post my review of the Ring too
and they were like hey we're pushing it
back to February so I just now post my
review of the ring too because they just
couldn't decide when to release this
thing and having seen it I can kind of
see why but surprisingly I didn't find
this movie utter shit it actually is
mostly competently made and it has a
couple good performances mostly from
Vincent D'Onofrio and a very fun
supporting role he shows up late in the
movie and the lead actress isn't too bad
she reminded me of Jessica Alba I mean
that's not really a bad thing
you look like Jessica Alba it hurt my
feelings how dare you say that like no
girl would ever say that they'd be like
oh thanks but honestly it actually is
fairly well directed there are some
effective sequences in rings this is not
an incompetent movie the horrific ly
dumb plane scene that we all saw in that
trailer
gracefully is over within the first few
minutes of the movie so we don't really
have to deal with that and it kind of
fades out in the memory but it does feel
really silly when you're watching it and
that leads me into my biggest issue with
rings where the other films felt very
primal and kind of vicious this movie
has a bit of a science fiction edge to
it when a college professor finds this
tape
he decides to run all these experiments
and he quickly discovers what the whole
mystery of the tape is and what you have
to do I won't ruin it for you if you've
never seen the other films and then he
starts hosting all of these underground
experiments he starts a cult of sorts
and I don't really understand the
timeline of this movie that's another
issue with it when a character watches a
tape they're supposed to die in seven
days but when we meet our main
characters the professor has already
watched the tape and then the guy goes
off to school and starts his own thing
and I guess it's six days later and
somehow this whole underground cult
experimentation class is going on and I
just don't get how all this happened in
such a small minut amount of time the
performances are somewhat off and on but
there isn't one person you zero in on
and just think man they should never be
in movies most everyone is as I said
competent you can watch this movie and I
mean that that's really it you can watch
this movie and it can be on so and like
I said if you have seen the ring films
then you know what they have to do to
sort of make it okay the way they do it
in this movie is so hilarious
I laughed actually in the theater I just
it's so funny like they actually I wish
I could just get into it I'm sure you
all know what it is but just in case the
one person who's watching who would be
me watching this video and go like oh my
god he ruined it I don't want to ruin it
for anybody so it's just the way they do
it in this movie it made me laugh in the
theatre so that's not very good this
movie isn't as bad as say incarnate or
the bye-bye man I actually liked it more
than the American the ring - I think
it's better than that movie which is
directed by Hadiya Nakata who made the
original ring so as you guys know I
thought that movie sucked and this one I
thought was going to be even worse and
despite some really silly plot lines and
some iffy acting this movie is okay at
best and just the fact that I'm saying
rings is OK at best surprises me because
I went into this movie clenched ready to
be violated I'm going to give rings I
see
it's not quite that terrible movie I was
expecting but you really can't get much
out of this movie all the character
tropes you expect and horror films like
this are there and they don't really do
that much different with it and some of
the mythology of this movie when
connected to the other ring films it
kind of messes with it a little bit the
way it ends is intriguing but I don't
really know if it makes sense within the
boundaries of this franchise guys thank
you so much as always for watching I do
appreciate it I'm going to try to see
the film the space between us is that
what's called the space but I don't know
let's try to see that one tomorrow guys
thank you very much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]